au Niger un expouchiste périt par le feu
de ses hommes 3 ans après son arrivée au
pouvoir par un coup d'État militaire le
Président Ibrahim Baré Masara a été tué
par ses propres gardes ce soir les
militaires contrôlent niam la capitale
son portrait signé erriic
Monier vous-même vous êtes contre ou
pour les coups d'État je suis contre les
coups d'État oui parce que j'estime que
la démocratie est universellement
reconnu comme étant un régime qui peut
être le plus bénéfique en tout cas pour
la personne humaine ainsi parlait
Ibrahim barem nasara général et pchiste
2 mois à peine après sa prise de pouvoir
par les armes au Niger il n'aimait pas
les coups d'État répétait-il celui
d'hier lui a coûté la vie IBM c'était
son surnom a été tué alors qu'il tentait
semble-t-il de quitter le
pays selon ce qui se dit dans la rue
qu'un qu'un obus a été tiré contre le
général Barret qui serait à 7 heure
décédé ainsi que une dizaine de
personnes et le Premier ministre a parlé
en disant que bon il la situation était
de nouveau calme et normal que le
gouvernement allait continuer à
travailler son destin politique IBM se
le forge le 27 janvier 1996 le Poch qu'
l'organise met fin à un blocage
politique total le président civil et
son premier ministre sont alors empêtrés
dans une cohabitation houleuse pour
beaucoup de Nigériens l'armée est le
seul recours les pays occidentaux et
notamment la France ne sont pas loin de
penser la même chose mais ne peuvent le
dire ouvertement alors qu'ils prônent la
démocratie en Afrique IBM doit passer
par les urnes il abandonne le tri pour
le boubou en juillet 1996 le voilà
président élu et enfin fréquentable la
France peut poursuivre l'exploitation de
l'uranium nigérien sans en rougir 6 mois
plus tard une manifestation de
l'opposition tourne à l'émeut et
rappelle que l'élection d'IBM n'a rien
réglé les problèmes économiques la
question touarec demeure l'armée grondde
et les promesses de démocratisation
restent vaines jusqu'à ces élections
locales de février dernier favorable à
l'opposition et annulé depuis les
rumeurs de coups d'État n'avaient pas
cessé